I am absolutely 100% fluent in Tagalog
after just one week and that's no lie
well actually it is but you don't hi
guys this is Paul last week I posted a
video telling you about my intention to
study Tagalog and the question is did I
actually follow through did I actually
study it and follow the plan that I had
told you about or did I sit around
watching TV and drinking some coke and
eating chips and whatever instead of
studying that's the question so I'd like
to show you a bit of my week what I did
and then show you the end result which
is some of what I learned during that
week so have a look and see what you
think
so that more please write that please
write namaha and meet later
Yakko go tom palynology
do something important
all right magandang a Lila heart I'm
Pangolin go I Paul nah
naca garlic Ajo makyla lacayo patawad da
hill Hendy Ajo Macedon marunong man
tagalog pero la caja in td9 Conte
Assange lingo belong
ah ho na da nang tagalog Nagala Hong nan
tagalog the hill madalasa hong puma
punku Latinas ISA home canadian pero
nasa
hapana hong ryoon naaku Totoro Ahonen
Inglis saga Epona's song Universidad at
gusto kong and trabajo trabajo Co soun
de Bercy dead
gusto con usted Cong maka are all non e
Botti bang lenguaje at gusto kong mag
lock bay at gusto codeine mug bossa
non-liberal at magar Allanon marin at my
own gusto kong guma 1 and video parasite
you tube at a similar non blog at sally
Bracken auras gusto Corinne McClure
kabocha kasama and Caillou began Co
India home nyaya modes the hill the hill
da he'll marry me aho ninagawa okay mag
and an ATO say Oh